[Music]
between 2007 and 2008 een outstanding
student debt is nearly tripled to 1.5
trillion and many worry it's the next
financial bubble like the housing crisis
of the 2000s observers are right to
worry about a student debt bubble but
it's not like the housing crisis
specifically the federal government
already backs 90% of student debt so bad
loans aren't about to bring down banks
and while taxpayers barely cost of bad
loans that's not where the big risks are
either most delinquent and default the
loans are small and the government
usually recovers most of the money
instead the real risk of a financial
bubble come from income based repayment
a program where borrowers pay a small
share of their earnings no matter their
debt loads and then have remaining
balances forgiven after 10 or 20 years
costs for this program skyrocketed with
debt for graduate professional degrees
dominating the program because those
students can both virtually unlimited
federal loans and unlimited loans and
loan forgiveness for graduate school
there's a real student debt bubble do
you think there's a student debt bubble
let us know in your comments also let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from a